- [Kelly] So usually, I'm not into horror
cause I'm scared so much of it,
but I like the island aspect
and like what's gonna happen,
for some reason that intrigues me.
But I hear your husband might be like me,
and he doesn't like horror.
So do you think he's going to watch it?
- No, he hasn't watched it.
- [Kelly] Oh (laughs) he has not.
- I also did another Mike Flanagan show,
called "The Haunting of Hill House."
- [Kelly] Oh yeah.
- And I took my husband to the premiere,
and he's never forgiven me.
(crowd laughs)
If anyone's seen "The Bent-Neck Lady."
- Yeah. Yup.
- Yeah, it's terrifying, right?
- [Kelly] No, but I do
love the island aspect.
I think it's a really cool
concept of how they're doing it.
- [Annabeth] Yeah, and I think
this is a little bit different
because it really investigates,
sort of, religious ideas.
What is-
- [Kelly] Which I love.
- Yep, very, it's about faith and science.
I play Dr. Sarah Gunning, who's
kind of the voice of reason
on the island when all of
these mysterious things
start to happen.
- [Kelly] Yeah, I love
what faith has brought,
I remember Stigmata way back in the day.
- [Annabeth] Oh yeah, yes.
- [Kelly] You saw that?
I love that. That scared
the crap out of me,
but I love how they tie that in.
- [Annabeth] Well, I think
religion kind of lends itself.
There are certain things
about religious things
that are scary, terrifying.
- But have your sons watched
it? Do they like scary stuff?
- Well, one of my sons loves
horror, my older son Cash,
but my younger son is very
much like my husband Wade,
and so no, they will not.
They'll watch Squid Game,
which I think is strangely -
- [Kelly] Everyone is talking about this,
I've never seen it,
everyone's talking about it.
- Yeah, I think it's
strangely more scarier to me
than Midnight Mass is.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Because it's just like real, like -
- [Kelly] That's just rude,
they're not watching your work.
- [Annabeth] Well we're
number one and number two,
I think, right?
- [Kelly] Okay, well whatever.
- [Annabeth] But yeah, I know
- It's rude.
- [Annabeth] Yes, I know, I'm
their mom. C'mon, watch me.
- [Kelly] Watch it, be scared for me.